hey let's check out what's inside the
Funko collector core box this is a Civil
War version this is April's month this
is a mail-in subscription service $25
every other month you get a new box full
of exclusive items from Funko every
month you get a pin this month we have
Black Panther go so I should have a
patch it looks like crossbones symbol
alright what is inside looks like a
commercial you can order stuff yeah so
if I didn't mention a click or calm all
right we have a t-shirt there's a
t-shirt every month there's our nice
soft shirts so Funko does do a line of
shirts now you see Civil War themed
whose side you on the correct answers
team cap looks like a lanyard I go to a
lot of conventions do you have your own
Funko lanyard there is also a comic book
with an exclusive cover so the Black
Panther number one it's a really cool
comic just came out right here we have a
2-pack
Captain America an Ironman
so that's pretty cool you two in there
what else do we have I think this is the
last thing we have adorbs this is
another line of there's Tony Stark dorbz
is helmet up the door's always so happy
I think that is it then you have your
box which you can keep it's got lots of
art inside it's got all the Avengers
Civil War so that is what you gets
highly collectable items you're into the
Funko you can subscribe to go to
collector Corps calm collector for calm
$25 every other month next one is women
of power so you'd be able to order that
that is for June let us know what you
think of these things